la troupe de la pièce en train muros
saluée par les scolaires après une
représentation uniquement dédié à ce
public venu du centre yvelines ah ben le
théâtre la barbacane et géré par un
syndicat intercommunal sept communes
sont associées et travaillent ensemble
sur la programmation
la spécificité de ce bâtiment c'est
qu'il a été construit au vert ya une
trentaine d'années avec l'idée que tout
le monde allait pouvoir se croiser et
une bibliothèque municipale un volet
associatif qui est porté par la ville de
ben avec différentes activités de la
pratique artistique
et puis dans notre salle de spectacle en
effet il ya spectacle mais aussi cinéma
plusieurs fois dans l'année les
représentations théâtrales sont suivis
de bord plateau un moyen de partager qui
permettent aux scolaires de se
familiariser avec le monde du spectacle
j'aime bien voilà transmettre un petit
savoir l'autre chose partager un peu
avec avec les jeunes parce que moi dans
mon parcours personnel j'ai souvent
rencontré des professeurs que ce soit de
sport de lettres de même de maths ou de
géographie qui m'ont souvent apporter
autre chose que leur matière en décembre
dernier l'établissement culturel a reçu
la visite d'aurore bergé la députée
yvelinois s'est inspiré de ce lieu pour
son rapport sur le développement de la
culture pour tous donc l'enjeu c'était
parler de comment à l'échelle d'un
territoire
on arrive à créer des mutualisations des
convergences des circulations qui
viennent parfois jusqu'à notre lieu
théâtre mais parfois c'est le théâtre
qui va sur sur les villes
il n'eut syndicats un accompagnement à
la culture qui a également permis à la
barbacane de devenir le premier lieu des
yvelines à porter le label scène
conventionnée pour la musique